foreign
what you're seeing here is a two-part
Dropship attack drone that deploys a
second drone to attack on the ground you
might be wondering how to make this
yourself so I'll show you how to create
it what parts are needed and how each
piece in this contraption works together
in tears of the Kingdom
firstly as a heads up this machine is
really energy hungry it's recommended
that you build this later in the game
when you have more zonai energy Wells
attaching a large battery anywhere on
the Drone can help a bit but you'll
eventually need to get your hands on a
good amount of crystallized charges to
give you more freedom with technology
like this
foreign
the parts needed here are two stakes one
homing cart one small battery two hover
stones four construct heads two lights
two beam emitters two rockets four
cannons and lastly one stabilizer keep
in mind that you may have to explore a
little bit more of the sky islands to
find more zonai dispensers to get
certain parts here most of these pieces
are mandatory but some can be removed or
interchanged with other things depending
on how creative you get so you can use
this video more as a baseline template
and if you have more ideas then go for
it yourself this machine has two parts
the main flying drop ship and the
Deployable ground drone the initial idea
was inspired by Pelicans from the Halo
Universe so you can kind of see the idea
behind this creation okay Charlie team
to start first work on the main ship you
can build things easier by using one
stake in the ground to use as a garage
Jack otherwise it gets kind of annoying
to keep flipping your Creations around
apply the first two hover stones in this
diamond orientation on top of each other
with the tail end raised so it can fit
the Drone underneath then apply
construct heads on both sides of the
front facing forward and on each end
attach a cannon and a beam emitter I
highly recommend this order because
otherwise the beam emitters can
sometimes detonate your cannonball's
mid-air before they even reach the enemy
which wastes precious battery and damage
then attach two stakes to the front end
at about this height this gives it a
good prop on the front side to keep it
level when placed on the ground the
light on the very bottom is kind of
optional lastly attach two Ruckus to the
tail of the ship at a 45 degree angle
and the key parts to this the small
battery underneath the tail of the ship
part 2 is a Deployable ground drone
first place the Homing cart down and
attach a single light facing forwards at
the center of the cart attach two
construct heads at the sides and
honestly at this point this can be
outfitted with emitters or weapons
however you see fit but more cannons
just turns out to be more fun after your
drone is outfitted with weapons finally
stick a stabilizer on the back this is
not 100 necessary but highly recommended
since when Landing your deployed drone
can sometimes flip upside down so the
stabilizer will keep it constantly
upright to keep it up and running now
carefully attach the Drone to the back
of the drop ship by Ultra hand attaching
it directly to the battery take off the
garage Jack stake and now you're ready
to roll this can now be dropped down
anywhere and can stand on its own using
the Drone as rear support and front
Stakes as front stands this whole system
works because when activated the rocket
boosters launch it upwards while keeping
it from overshooting by hovering with
the two hover stones and because it uses
a battery on the back first once it's
depleted it disappears and disk connects
basically dropping the tow hook for your
deployed drone from way up high
now the caveat with any robot is because
robots have friendly fire on I would
just recommend enjoying the show and
sitting on high ground because joining
in on the fun will probably get you
killed too the second thing is link
needs to be in range of both of the
Contraptions for them to stay running
being too far away will shut them down
so either activate it towards link or
simply sit on top of the drop ship
itself and hang out for a ride
and there you go have fun demolishing
any enemy that comes your way with your
brand new attack Dropship and let us
know if you enjoy by liking this video
and stay tuned for more cool tiers of
the Kingdom content here on Gamespot